so guys and girls we're going to start
off with a quote everyone knows a
comedian called chris rock right
yeah chris rock said
women
children
and dogs
are loved unconditionally
men are only loved when they can provide
something
what do we think about that
are men
only loved by condition
oh totally 100
i think it's
it's part of the journey for a man to
understand that when you beca when
you're transitioning from being a boy
into a man
and realizing that it's like that
unconditional love and acceptance you
get from your mum
is not shared by the rest of the world
and then you know it's about that
struggle to
understand you know it's not necessarily
going to come
you know i kind of put it you you're
gonna get love but only based upon the
value you can create for yourself
and that's it
you know when i've seen guys who don't
get that or they're caught in this
delusion
or they're not getting you know
they've not had that basis of
preparation from like their parents
they really struggle they really
struggle as as
developing into men because you know you
need that
self-reliance because if you're walking
around in the world
wait wanting to feel that unconditional
love
then you know you you've got a long wait
you've got a really long way as a man
do you feel like men
aren't loved
or is there um stipulations to a man
being saying not loved
are there stipulations to a man being
loved
yeah i mean i i don't think that um
women really love men like that you know
i mean there's always a condition
there's definitely always a condition to
it you know what i mean um
i think that
you've
when you when you grow up you learn this
like very quickly
you learn this very quickly i think um
when you look at your your uh
the relationships from
um
like uncles aunties and things like that
and then you look at the relationships
between you like your your mother and
father you can instantly see this do you
know what i mean
and i think the reason why a lot of uh
men are
a lot of relationships break up
or even marriages break up
is be most of it's to do with financial
most of it's financial reasons
so that should show you that a lot of
the time
you know so bro guys don't deserve love
well
i think i think i think
i think women want a lot they want to
love you but it's just they if you're
looking at it from a nature standpoint
they just just can't they just can't do
it after a certain they just after a
certain time if you're not
providing you're not showing that you're
you're you know you're
on job you're on point then you know
it's it's something in them just it just
clicks off
lady
do you want to go first
so i've just i've been thinking this
quite a lot
and some of it something you said was
like you know oh you said that after
your mum like no one else speaking to
the mic sorry that after your mum no one
else is going to love you
unconditionally
that's what i'm thinking isn't that only
people gonna love you unconditionally is
your parents is your mom and dad like
why why do you expect anyone else to
cover us as unconditional as well i mean
yes granted your your partner your kids
should but they're always gonna have
like qualms of you
and i and i so i feel like i don't know
cases and i could be wrong where women
are loved unconditionally
like you know in in my opinion
so i think only people are gonna love
you is your parents now for that it's
the world and i'm not gonna love you
this you got something well the thing
about
like a woman can do nothing and a man
will love her
like she can just exist
where sorry where whereas like men have
to become so they have to get good at
talking to women they have to understand
how we operate they have to learn how to
make money they have to learn
all these different things in order to
attract deaths where women can just
exist isn't that
isn't that a fault of a man not having
enough standards so if we are putting a
standard of i'll have to a b and c for
me to love you because men say i don't
care about her money i don't care about
what she does anything i want to take
whatever girl i want that's a them
problem not necessarily like a societal
problem because
like if you if you want to love someone
from doing nothing that's kind of on you
really so i think it's more well it's
like when when men meet a new girl right
and they say to the boys i've met a new
girl and the boys say what does she look
like
right
when
women meet a new man
when we say i've met this new guy you
guys what does he do
it's totally different so women want to
know what this guy can do
and men want to know what she looks like
i think we asked both i was pretty like
what'd he do yeah i think always what
you look like first because i need to
know what it looks like
then it's like oh what does he do but
it's very important in in in a woman's
conversation what he does that i don't i
don't think that's i don't think that's
true you wouldn't ask what he looks like
yes i would yeah
what does he look like go on what's up
show me his picture hundred percent yeah
no i i say that well i'm not obviously
i'm not a girl but i do your initial
though so would it be the first thing
you ask yes yes
well you know women women are
different in 2022 where they almost rate
men the way that
like men used to rate women
where they value looks higher than they
ever have because of the development of
birth control where before like they had
to prioritize other things because they
had the risk of getting pregnant so they
couldn't just sleep with the hot guy
but now like women put looks higher
because they can't they have birth
control so they can sleep with the haka
even if he's not going to stick around
yeah or before it was more like beta
like beta is that working for us to say
a woman put in a man's looks sorry his
looks over what he can provide
definitely
yeah it won't work it's not that's
that's why we say broke men don't
deserve love that's the whole point of
the campaign is like
we don't think it's enough so no
so then would you would you say fat
chicks don't deserve love on the same
token i mean look someone's gonna love a
homosexual someone's gonna love a fat
chick so you know someone's gonna get
theirs no no not not for men though
because like most historically one out
of three men didn't reproduce
and i think it's actually less than that
i don't know the exact number but eighty
percent of women reproduced historically
i think it's forty percent of men
reproduced historically
so women in general can always get love
from someone but men they can't well how
why do you define that as love like just
because they
had someone that could reproduce with
that doesn't necessarily mean they were
loved
because
what do you mean the women are the men
so the women so you're counting love
just by reproduction right so you're
saying because women were able 80
percent of women were able to reproduce
that then means that 80 percent of women
were loved well i'm saying that there's
always someone that's gonna date a girl
because a third of like one out of three
men haven't had sex in the past year
or is a virgin under 30. so i'm saying
there's always someone like you've seen
my 600 pound life yeah they they all
have they all have boyfriends yeah but
it's not the same vice versa i i i think
a bright man can find love i mean the
campaign is not but
to say like i haven't heard stories
about a man moving in a man not working
am i not doing stuff but he's got a girl
by his side his friend is lifestyle i'll
be lying i've heard it
but typically those guys are hot
or they they're really good at talking
to women they have something they're
good in bed too honestly yeah they have
something that's keeping the girl in
there yeah there's multiple there's
there's different values i mean if it's
the conventional providing value like
it's got a good job that's one or good
income whatever there's one value but if
it's like
it provides emotional excitement and you
know whether it be being toxic or how
he's gonna do that
then he can be broke i mean i know when
i was younger
i used to run nightclubs and i'd had no
money i just had a really good social
circle
i had access to whether it be drink free
dinners and all that stuff
i had those things
i didn't i wasn't really a good prospect
but it allowed me to have running get
access
so again you because you could provide
something
you had access
yeah i had access before but that kind
of super like kind of turbo charged it
when i was like 19 20.
um
because that slogan broke men don't
deserve love like pearl was saying if a
slogan or a hashtag was like fat women
don't deserve love it would be a thing
like it would be like uh they're both to
be an uproar you can't say that you're
fat shaming
what broke guys don't deserve love yeah